[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants
patron je prends mon le cheval n'est
bien sûr nounours et joue de son étude
et sans et tu ne restes pas trop
longtemps le nom bon le cheval je
descends beaucoup mais en fait nicolas
moi tu me montaigne mais je te dis que
le pauvre vue pas preneur bonsoir mes
enfants aux bons soirs nous tiens tu
tombe bien de ce postulat prenait lé
elle trouve plus au peigne et moi je
trouve plus mes pantoufles on trouve
plus rien dans cette maison et oui
depuis cas d athènes veut qu'il fallait
tout bien rangée et b gâche tout ils
nous on trouve plus rien mais voyons en
cherchant bien nous allons le trouve nul
mais non il n'est pas là ma brosse à
dents aussi a disparu
ashiq la mienne aussi allons alors on va
tous retrouvés voyons un peu pas là
[Musique]
au château haut niveau dimanche viennent
dit scott
aussi quand c'est trop fort le shérif
on ne peut pas les gros des ces petits
ils mettent de l'ordre ou son team
s'adresse bien voir bonsoir mes petits
neveux mais c'est magnifique
vous avez tout ranger oui c'est
magnifique tu parles si tu fais un verre
d'eau ya plus de faire un geste au bon
j'aimerais bien un petit verre de
quelque chose de bon mecheri dites à
votre tonton les verts les verts ale
voilà tout et tu te rends compte l'ours
d'or la poubelle avec monthey et avec
mon livre d'image y avait ma brouette
earth est la mienne et mary bah tiens ça
suffit ça suffit
demain vous mettrez tout en ordre
compris allons mais ces rubans au dodo 2
[Musique]
des drôles de qu'aucun d'eux ne veut nos
noces au lou dobbs de 3,2
le shérif j'espère mes petits amis que
vous ne faites pas comme rémi toto et
fanfan lorsque vous ranger vos affaires
il faut mettre chaque chose à sa place à
2 voilà nounours haut niveau au trot en
route fidèle compagnon
venue des enfants fait de bourrel à deux
balles
[Musique]